[Music]
reading the newspaper over a cup of
coffee that's Donna Karlson's morning
ritual she's a woman of principle and
has been for a hundred and six years she
still enjoys life to the fullest and has
retained her sense of curiosity
I live in the here and now I don't think
about tomorrow or that I could die
tomorrow I'll be gone soon enough anyway
Dean they don't know but Dagny Carlson's
life isn't over yet and she doesn't want
to miss a single thing that's happening
in the world outside her little
apartment in Stockholm so she spends a
lot of time on the Internet
her computer is like a friend who helps
her keep in contact with the outside
world relatives gave her the PC and she
gradually familiarized herself with the
strange contraption after doing without
one for a century I've had the computer
since I was 99 or a hundred when you're
over ninety buying a computer doesn't
seem too sensible but now Dagny Carlson
couldn't do without her PC it's given
her life a whole new meaning
I've gotten very used to it I can keep
in touch with my friends without even
having to pay postage I can read the
news it's really good now you have to go
yes but just reading what others have
written isn't exciting enough for this
sprightly senior so she's also a
passionate blogger her blog is entitled
blog um and MiG Swedish for blog with me
when I was young I always wanted to be a
writer but there were so many good books
around that it made no sense to produce
a poorly written one when I blog I don't
have to write about a specific topic I
do what I want but if I weren't this old
no one would pay much attention but
since she is a hundred and six
she's amassed a huge following nine year
olds write comments and say you're
really cool
that makes me really proud
this new channel my eldest is told and
these fans who are still young at heart
have come to London University to honour
her efforts here a five-hour journey
south from Stockholm
Donnie Carlson is receiving an award
from the Swedish gerontological Society
allowed at the blogger as a model for
how older Swedes can keep active and
this centenarian is happy to share her
passion with others if a day goes by and
I don't post anything on my blog folks
think that I've died the gerontology
award comes with 2000 euros and prize
money and Dagny Carlson plans to use it
to throw herself a nice birthday party
[Applause]
[Music]
but she's happiest while spending time
on her computer at home she says that
the comments she receives about her blog
are always very polite and nice though
she knows not everyone on the net
believes seniors has something to say
not many people think that smart old
folks exist but it does happen
she believes using computers helps the
older generation stay young and Daphne
Carlson still feels young herself even
at the age of 106